[موسيقى]
ونحييكم مشاهدينا من جديد اعتقلت الشرطه
الالمانيه 25 شخصا يشتبه بانتمائهم لجماعه
حركه مواطن والرايخ في اقصى اليمين او من
اقصى اليمين الرافدين لدستوريه المانيا
وداعين للاطاحه بالحكومه وذلك بعد حمله
تفتيش واسعه شملت اكثر من 100 موقع في
احدى عشره ولايه ووصف وزير العدل الالماني
ماركو بوشمان وصف هذه المداهمات بانها
عمليه لمكافحه الارهاب مضيفا ان المشتبه
بهم ربما خط طول سنه هجمات مسلحه تستهدف
مؤسسات الدوله ولفت تقارير المانيه الى ان
المتهمين خططوا لي اضرابات منهجته وعنيفه
وكانت بحوزتهم اسلحته اثناء اعتقالهم كما
ذكر للدعاء ان عناصر من الحركه تواصلوا مع
ممثلين دبلوماسيين روس في المقابل نفقه
السفاره الروسيه في برلين اي بطل لها مع
اي جماعات ارهابيه او خارجه عن القانون او
كيانات غير شرعيه في المانيا واكدت في
بيان انها لا تقيم اتصالات مع هذه
الجماعات من جهته وصف الكريم لان
المداهمات الجاريه ضد جماعه اقصى اليمين
بانها شان داخلي لا علاقه لروسيا به
[موسيقى]
نفهم اكثر ما يحدث في المانيا مع برلين
كتب الصحفي ياسين اهلا بك ومن موسكو
المختصر في شؤون السياسيه والاستراتيجيه
اهلا بكم
امم الادعاء العام الالماني يتحدث عن
محاوله انقلاب عن احباط المانيا لمحاوله
انقلاب ولكن البعث قال وكان هناك مبالغه
في القول بان هناك محاوله فعليه للانقلاب
عاده الانقلاب يتم بدفع من مؤسسه امنيه
الجيش خاصه
فنحن نتحدث عن مجموعه هل هي خطيره بخطوره
امكانيه احداث او الدفع بانقلاب داخلي
حقيقي
تحياتي لكي انت تحياتي لجميع مشاهدي قناه
العربيه ولضيفك من موسكو الموضوع عن
المدعي العام
افرادت ان تسقوا على البرلمان الالماني
وان تحتل هذا البرلمان الالماني بما معناه
اللي هو السلطه التشريعيه الموجوده في
المانيا ومن هناك يتم التخطيط فيما بعد
بما بعد هذه العمليه ولكن الشرطه
الالمانيه والقوات الالمانيه احمقت هذا
المخطط قبل بدايته يعتقد ان هناك بعض
المصادر ان هذه العمليه كانت ستقوم في
القريب العاجل
الى كميه المداهمات والاعتقالات
مختصين في هذه العمليه بالاضافه الى تاثير
سياسي تم القبض عليهم نحن نتحدث عن
سياسيين ونتحدث عن قاضيه في البرلمان
قاضيه كانت نائمه من حزب البديل نحن هنا
نتحدث عن هناك في السلطه في الجيش في
القوات الخاصه الضباط حاليا وضباط في قوات
الاحتياط الالماني لذلك اعتقد ان
ماليه كانت هي بما معناه مداهمه هذا
البرلمان
لما سيتم فيما بعد في هذه العمليه بما
يسمى بالريس مواطنيه
همم سيده الينا البعض يقول ليس هناك دخان
ذو النار همم
ولماذا الزوج بروسيا في هذا الموضوع خاصه
وانه مواطنه او اقصى اليمين الالماني
المعروف حتى وان انكر في هذه الحاله
علاقتهم بديبلوماسيان الروس ولكن معروفه
علاقتهم بروسيا على امتداد عقود فلماذا
طرح اسم روسيا في هذا الموضوع بتحديث في
هذا التوقيت
مساء الخير انا شخصيا التقيت ببعض الشاشه
الالمان وهم مواليد لروسيا مثلا من
البديل لالمانيا
ولكن هم موجودين في برلمان المانيا هما
قوى سياسيه منظمه وليست لهم اي علاقه
بشيء اسمهم مؤامره او انقلاب
بهذه الحاله انا اعتقد انه هذا الدخان
بدون نار لانه اوروبا كانه عندها هاجسس
ساره وهو مرتبط بعروسه هذه التهامي هي
باطله حتى المتحدث همم
توجيه هذه جبتها
وكانك تشككين ليس فقط في همم طرح اسم
روسيا كان متفاعل مع هذه الحركه ولكنك
تشككين اكثر من ذلك تشكين في
ان يكون هناك تخطيط فعلي من هذه المجموعه
من مواطنين رايح صحيح صحيح
والان ووجدت ان هناك متقاعدين الى اخره
يعني هي همم هذا الشيء غريبه للغايه وهناك
كانه ولي العهد
وهمم واسمه
ومواطن اسمها روسي وكل هذا غريب للغايه
وعلى هناك تراجع اصبح من قبل الحكومه
المانيا بالنسبه لتوجيهاتهم لاروسه من
الواضح انه رؤوس ليس لها اي ضعف في هذا
الشيء
سيد ياسين هل تستغرب كظيفته اقل تضع نقاط
استفهام بخصوص هذه الادعاءات او هذا
التاكيد هو هي تصريحات من الدعاء العام في
الواقعه همم
ضيفتي تقول بان همم المجموعه غير قاده على
احداث ما همم سمي بانقلاب حتى على المستوى
الاجتماعي
هل تتفق معها
لا لا المدعي العام يقول ان هناك امراه
ذات اصول الروسيه كانت حلقه الوصل
بعض الاشخاص التنظيم وما بين السفاره
الروسيه
تحدث الان في تواصل امراه روسيه بين احد
ابرز الشخصيات في هذا التنظيم وما بين احد
الشخصيات في السفاره الروسيه مدى صدقيه
ذلك الموضوع بعد التحديث سيتم الكشف عن عن
ذلك الموضوع بعد التحقيق ولكن ليس هناك
نار بدون دخان
اعتقد ان اعتقد ان روسيا حسب اعتقادي لا
تريد روسي ان تدخل في اما اخرى بعد الحرب
على اوكرانيا وهذا الفشل الدريع لدى الدب
الروسي نحن نتحدث الان عن اكثر من ثمانيه
اشهر وما زال الدب الروسي يعاني في الشرق
الاوكراني لا اعتقد ان هناك تدخل روسي في
هذه التنظيم ولكن اعتقد ان روسيا تحاول
زعزعه النظام في السياسه في جميع اوروبا
حتى تكسب هذه الاصوات نحن نرى الان ان
روسيا تبدا بدات في
وضع البنيه التحتيه والطاقه وجميع المناحي
الحياه وفي جميع اوكرانيا تحت نيران
المدافع والصواريخ الذي حتى تعطي الفرد
الاوكراني المعنى ان ان ان لن نعيش بحريه
كامله ان ليس لدينا اي اي طاقه ليس لديها
اي خيارات اخرى سواء
في روسيا لديها همم منفعه في احداث
الزعزعه فداخل الاوروبي نتحدث عن المانيا
في هذه الحاله اكيد لا تحاول همم داخل
المانيا ابدا روسيا ليست لديها مصلحه في
هذا الشيء ليست لها اي علاقه في ما يحدث
هذا
ولكن ما الذي تفعله صيدا روسيه همم اكد
الذي العام بانها تتواصل مع هذه المجموعه
التي ثبت فيما بعد بان هذه المجموعه تحضر
لي الدخول البرلمان لمحاوله احداث همم او
الدفعه الانقلاب
انا متاكد يا انه ااه ليست لها اي علاقه
بحكومه روسيا هناك المانوس يعني المان من
جنسيته روسيا من روسيا السابقين فهنا
يوميات مختلفه ولكن روسيا ليست لها مصلحه
بهذا الشيء ولكن من الاساس استاذ ياسين
كيف تعيش هذه المجموعه في داخل الالماني
هي مجموعه من اقصى اليمين ترفض الدستور
تدعو للاطاحه بالحكومه هل نتحدث عن قاعده
شعبيه مهمه لهذه المجموعه او تكتسبها هذه
المجموعه شيئا
البدايه الحركه اليمنيه المتطرفه هذه
الريخ مواطنيه الريخ موجوده في بعض
الولايات الالمانيه وفي عام 2016 قام احد
المنتمين لهذا التنظيم الارهابي كما
وصفها السلطات الالمانيه بقتل ضابط الماني
وقد تم الحكم عليه في عام 2017 في الحكم
بالسجل حياه كانت اعدادهم قليله اخر
التصريحات المهمه للسلطات الالمانيه تقول
ان هناك 21,000 شخص منتمي لهذا التيار
كم عدد سكان المانيا حتى نفهم لانه يبدا
21,000
81 مليون سنه
قادره على ان تحدث اي او ان تؤثر في داخل
الالماني
المهم ان من ينتمي الى تلك المجموعه نحن
هنا راينا اليوم هو قاضي سابق فاضي حاليه
وهي سابقه من حزب البديل هناك ضباط صف
هناك ضباط في القوات الخاصه
حينما نتحدث عن العدد ليس كبير ولكن المهم
بل ينتمي الى تلك المجموعه دعيني اضيف
كلمه اخرى المهم
ازعل الموجوده لدى هذه الزمره الصغيره ال
ضد هي زياده بعد موجه النازحين واللاجئين
التي دخلت الملكه عام 2015 ايضا لا يمكن
ان نضع ذلك بعيدا عن ما يحدث في القاره
الاوروبيه نحن هنا نتحدث عن الاخوه
الايطاليه في الاخوه اخوه ايطاليا الحزب
الذي يراسل اهل السلطه نحن نتحدث عن
الاتحاد السويدي في السويد نحن نتحدث عن
ذكرى اوبن الذي هو يتدعم السلطه هي اهداف
يمنيه تعيش في المجتمع الالماني ولكن ان
يصل الى حد انهم يريدون الدخول سياسيه
هذا البرلمان ويمكن ان يكون لديهم اسلحه
المعلومات التي
ان هناك ان هناك اجتماعات السريه سنويه
يقوم بها هذا الحزب ولديهم جناح عسكري
ولكن لم تقم السلطات المانيا جميع هذه ال-
ال- الاماكن او اين يتدربون او مثل كميه
الاس حتى لو حتى لو تكون هناك بعض البلبله
لدى الشعب الالماني ماذا تفعل اشرقات
الامنيه لغايه الان وبما انهم هادئ هؤلاء
موجودين من عام
2006 جديد
ما هي نقاط التقاء روسيا بهذه المجموعه
بمواطنيه رايخ خاصه وان كل التقارير تؤكد
بان هناك تواصل مستمر وهناك محاوله ل همم
ان يكون او ان تكون هذه المجموعه قريبه
دائما من النظام الروسي ما تفسير
التقاء فانا اعتقد انه هناك مشكله في
اوروبا نفسها هي مشكله نفسيه تجاه روسيا
روسيا مستعيده للتعاون مع المانيا ليست
لها اي علاقه بمثل هذه المجموعات المتركه
على بعض التقارير من المانيا التي تقول
بان هذه المجموعه كانت لها ليس فقط لقاءات
ولكن هي في تواصل مستمر مع دبلوماسيين روس
هذا ما اوردته بعض التقارير الالمانيه
نحن الان نتحدث عن المدعي عام ونحن نتحدث
عن المشتبهين في قضيه قضيه عباره عن قضيه
انقلاب داخل المانيا مدى صدقيه ذلك
الموضوع هو بعد التحقيق ولكن ان يتم مزج
امراه روسيه ذات اصول روسيه او روسيه
الاصل في هذا التحقيق يدل على ان هناك
السفاره الروسيه مع تلك المجموعه مدرسه
ولديها مواقف سياسيه تتحداها وبالتالي همم
ما هو تفسيرك هذا الملف الاضافي
لا انا استبعد اولا انا استبعد كل شيء
ستدخل في هذه
المعمعه الكبيره هناك التدخل ويمكن ان
ينكسر ذلك الموضوع ولكن وجود شخص روسي في
هذا الموضوع يمكن ان يؤثر على علاقات
الروسيه الالمانيه بشكل نهائي
سلميه واعاده المياه الى مجاريها ولكن ثبت
هذا الموضوع روس يعتقد وراء عمليه
انقلابيه فا انا اعتقد ان السلطات
الالمانيه وان السياسه الالمانيه ستكون
مغايره بشكل كبير ااه ضد
روسيافل الباب نهائيا امام اي مستوى مع مع
الطرف الروسي
شكرا جزيلا شكرا على المشاركه من موسكو او
من بالين او لان الكتب الصحفيه باشمه
ياسين واا الشكر كذلك لضيفتي من موسكو
المختصه في شؤون السياسيه ولا استراتيجيه
لان السبون هنا شكرا لكم